hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay we're gonna
go fix the columns array because someone
smashed it up the jerks oh there we go
power node okay um okay oh yeah
it's actually kind of creepy
my camera keeps assuming it
what hey hi buddy huh oh nothing
scare me
not even an orchestral soundtrack and
now what was the point of that as it
comes ray have to be so far it seems
like a waste of [ __ ] that's me sure
there are lines symmetrically so there
are no power gap okay I know what that
means
why do I know what symmetric means wait
you think I'm stupid was that what I get
why don't you tell me
medium air can schematic boring oh come
on Isaac really missed that
really okay there's blood going from
that chair to that vent but there's the
vents not broken so I don't know how
that happened whatever I don't care I'm
just playing the game babe power node
yes Romo Manny why don't you give me
that more equipment they must be gearing
me up for something because they've been
giving a lot equipment for the past few
minutes now what do we got so I'm big in
here ready for you
masks on
I see yeah uh what's that guy tail
I got your tail I'll cut your tail off
now you think about that come on I see
you down there - hot dog fly through the
air can't even touch it
no get out of these don't even try it
nope Oh what no ed gone
your head didn't go but at least you
have the good sense to die oh I see
at dawn
out here oh yeah give me all your help I
like it
those cell dude cam here box now whoa
say you gently right there this haha yep
that sounds about right
boy okay um is it great up there
I'm assuming the green ones are good
ones and symmetrically I guess I need to
put them all in a line or a liner circle
I'm guessing a circle that would make
the most sense since the whole room is
circular but what's the circle do I put
them in broken put it in the wrong way
loser
yeah that was right in there is that a
good sound or a bad sound I don't know I
can't tell with these things um ah where
are the good ones
cannot see a thing there's another one I
got this don't worry guys I got this
give it that's that gimme gimme there we
go
all right um another Brooke ones over
there so get out of there go away and I
need to get over there I said I need to
get over there don't back sass me what I
will Danger Danger
all right that's okay there's another
good one
why is the roof of goobie I don't look
good okay no no come here
control is to jump button for some
strange reason coming got ya
hey there we go will do lady and I
expect when we gather here laughs you're
gonna do some kind of review oh wait I
have a girlfriend sorry well they can
both join in no that's that's
misogynistic bingo fail shoot those
beams of information on all frequencies
to USG Ishimura photo in response to
your SOS save us picked up your escape
pod number 47 and our wound to your
position
uh-huh but Hammond every 30 salmon get
after you respond
what isn't does the escape pod Hammond
jettison oh oh oh come on
of course valor come in valor oh boy
that's me I think there's something big
oh that's why there's no something
organic I don't know what it is we don't
care we have to get the doors open to
transmit to the Balor you should have a
clear shot from a DF Kenneth 48 get to
the Ken and code out into space okay
where am I going
oh there we go okay go back on the
unnecessarily long trail
Bonnie get back here I just want to talk
with you
oh I get to shoot one of the big guns in
I like those things plus a terrible shot
but heck it's a big giant monster
kidnapper Boosh
that's moose you two get smooshed baby
maybe not here let's go shoot us a big
time monster ha ha ha no no since when
can you use elevators
that's not fair it's not fair at all
I'll do you yeah
fall down in shame yeah and go through
the boom yeah get out of here I just bit
my tongue out Oh what Andy that's right
there oh there we go
am I going the right way probably I mean
it sort of just points me in the right
direction anyway I don't even think I
need the direction marker for most
things except for when things are in the
same room and together you're a certain
way but I've even gone the wrong way and
not followed my marker and still I got
the objective done so whyever Oh
who's out there
ah boo writing no good to do nudity
okay wouldn't it be bad to take this off
of asteroid killing duty and instead
upar note and step focus on something
else not killing asteroids manual
override yeah oh hello your big get
ready for some fun Oh big yellow markers
hi president
no that's a bad monster
bad button you need to be taught a
lesson
the three at me I now overheat
also batteries
oh no no debris
uh debris debris
of South Africans
I should be sure Oh God won't even lose
their exploding barrels
Cheeta where I can't get
double-barreled
Oh
[Music]
hi buddy yeah I've got you oh man I
should probably be for this invisible
I'm dizzy oh god another one doesn't
care
okay nope not today
[Music]
some trick of scale but they got
ah
no not today
Oh
[Music]
take your medicine
I did this
not even 40
there we go finally
the target
she where it is shoot where it's gonna
which means shoot bullets everywhere
there we go the shoot bullets everywhere
stairs there you go God get out of here
get off my ship Kendra Daniels on the
USG Ishimura do not know the share usm
ballast counter Daniel from usglc you
cannot open this game huh
don't come any closer
oh boy come on really really it's a
military ship oh it's full of soldiers
what what it's a military ship full of
soldiers with guns
thank god you're right
I've been trying to reach you someone's
blocking my rig signal remotely to the
signal block there's someone else on
this oh it's the crazy guy idiot the
cesium [ __ ] the chain of command we have
to get the hell out of here I think I've
located a shuttle on the crew dinner oh
right look says it needs a new
singularity call but we can probably
salvage one from the valor I can see the
tail end of it sticking out from the
side vision more okay I'm headed down
there now to find a way inside I'll meet
you there
about the shuttle we might have a chance
of getting out of here no baby just a
cargo bay and see if you can help
Hammond why don't you dishes we may not
last long done last along with my help
but I've been foreshadowing his death
throughout the entire game okay yeah I
can't believe I've totally forgotten
about that crazy psychopath
dr. Mercer was his name dr. Mercer yeah
I I've completely forgotten about him I
mean he hasn't bothered me ever since I
froze his abomination so why should I
care all right kill the big monster and
crashes you seriously that's a military
ship one one monster should not take
over a ship and even if it did manage to
like get in the vents it would take a
while this ship took a while to get all
killed
right I mean people were walking around
going hey the ships under attack we
should do something about that and then
then they did nothing so quickly no hand
did where's your other hand friend yes
all right let me just tap this old save
station
come on tap it tap death yeah all right
Punk okay
and that'll do it for today's episode
thank you guys so much for watching as
always I appreciate every single one of
you and I think I think I'm hoping that
this microphone is good I'm after this
episode I'm gonna check the audio but
hope you like the new microphone and I
hope it makes my voice sound as smooth
as butter
and if it doesn't then just give it time
because I'm still gonna be tweaking it
if it's not perfect right now
and if it doesn't sound great it will
soon so thank you guys again for
watching and I will see you in the next
part
bye bye